vous arrivez maintenant pas du tout
interview jugement dernier
patrick bruel
oui quand tu étais petit as tu me
regarder sous le bureau de la maîtresse
pour voir sa culotte
oui mais pas petit un peu plus tard en
troisième
professeur d'espagnol au lycée henri iv
voilà j'ai tout dit ces deux jugements
vernet patrick bruel à l'école 1 tu
jouer au docteur avec tes copains plus
avec mes copines avec un ami espagnol
les affaires françaises
as tu en perds mais des élèves de sexe
féminin dans les cabinets nom bizarre
voici trois ans bah oui pourquoi tu veux
savoir gré pu s'enfermer avec elle mais
pour le premier en faire ensuite on
sature menti de devenir une star mais il
a dit qu'il était temps ça marche la
nature ni et certains de tes années
n'ont pas aimé gré tu lui as tu
pardonnes été éliminés pas toujours
quand tu es devenu une star
as-tu profiter le tas notoriété pour
obtenir des avantages particuliers
et voilà on y est on est en plein dans
la rubrique fellation groupe est
allongée
heureux temps
c'est exactement ce qu'ils voulaient
éviter il voulait pas répondre si si
j'ai obtenu des avantages particuliers
par le fait d'être connu
en effet mais je n'ai pas spécialement
chercher et là tu chantes des chansons
anciennes pour défaire des plus vieilles
tu profiter de sa notoriété pour exiger
négatif contre nature pas de préciser
charlie jérémy comment tu parle à dieu
camarades patrie mais oui c'est il
arrivé de refuser de faire l'amour en
prétextant une migraine
oui
arrêtez vous dénigrez d'absorber des
substances illicites avant de faire
l'amour nom du peuple
ben non jamais bon bah non non non j'ai
jamais essayé
non est ce que tu te reprends je me suis
jamais pendu vient zapping
entre deux
son nom